senator thanks for coming to see us at
the end of a
nothing much going on i know but thanks
for having me i should i should warn you
and i should say hello that i want to
welcome our twitter and wsu.com
audiences out there i know you're a big
twitter user so
um
my staff is more than i am
so we started off uh our ceo council
last night with mitch mcconnell and the
first thing we talked about was the debt
ceiling and the defense officers
and they seem to be done so that means
yeah you got one big thing in your party
that your party is looking at and that's
build back better
chuck schumer
has says it will pass the senate by
christmas which is now what two and a
half weeks away what do you say well you
know he's in charge of the calendar so
wherever he's going to set it and it's
time to vote we vote
but you must be negotiating you're
talking to them
pardon but but if you give us more where
is the only thing i would say is that
first of all the parliamentarian is
going through what they call the scrub
to see if it fits in the reconciliation
we're doing so much in reconciliation
anymore and between you and i it was
never intended to be used for major
policy changes reconciliations for
budgetary matters mostly
but it has
been spread out to this so the
parliamentarians see if it meets the
bird rule and they call it the bird bath
to see if it fits and should fit or
should not fit and they'll decide what's
in it now we haven't seen the final
final text on it so for me to speak on
it to say
yes i could be for this or no i'm not
going to be for that or you need to
change this or that until i see see the
legislation is that hard to say that
understanding that you don't have a
specific bill to comment on you don't
have a specific piece of legislation
you have commented on different policies
and ideas that have been floated
you have expressed some concern about
budgeting
uh what you call budgeting gimmicks you
you've expressed some question about
some policies so
at least we're all going to be watching
this in the next couple weeks we're all
gonna be wondering if this bill
is is gonna pass or not we're all gonna
know that you're at the center can you
give us a
some bottom line framing of how you will
think about whatever comes your way
what's gonna be important to you or
what's gonna be
uh what you what's going to be a trigger
line for you matt we were all we were
all uh
warned if you will uh by economists back
in january of this year
uh that
we were going to be coming out of this
and when we came out the dependent
demand was going to be strong
we'd better be ready to go so they said
you know maybe the unemployment benefits
ought to stop in may
because that sends a signal and if it
had not recovered by that time we could
have extended that we always have done
that but they were determined to go to
september october remember when we shut
down for 12 hours
i just said you know and then they
wanted to raise it to 400
i said you know guys i think you heard
the same briefing i heard
now all of a sudden you want me to go
back to west virginia and say boys if
you can just stand employed for a little
longer you'll get a raise
none of this made sense to me nothing
made sense to me and i said let's get
back to work let's let's get up and go
get ready
and it's uh and we can see the effects
of that we had people at that time
saying inflation will be transitory we
had 17 nobel laureates saying it's going
to be no problem
well 17 nobel laureates were wrong
and now the feds are even saying
it's not transitory and they're hoping
it'll reduce
and we don't know we'll have to wait and
see but the bottom line is
i was concerned then and i said let's
take a strategic pause i put an op-ed in
the wall street journal for that reason
and i thought long and hard about that
my reason for saying that and i still
feel strongly about that
is the unknown we're facing today is
much greater
than the need that people believe in
this
aspirational bill that we're looking at
and we've got to make sure we get this
right we just can't
continue to flood the market as we've
done so it's it would be
inferring from what you're saying it
would be fair
it sounds like to say that you're going
to look particularly closely at
how it's funded how it's paid for
what the budgetary structure is like and
what the consensus
or what your conclusion or the consensus
is on the effect on inflation in the
economy absolutely
we did have we have had a couple man if
i can say if i i'm so sorry to interrupt
but if i could say one thing the bill
started out they said it's 6 trillion
and they said we cut it down to 3.5
trillion
and now they say well joe you've been in
there and you've just said it can't be
that big and we just got to look at now
we're down to anywhere from 175 i think
it came from the house at 2.2
they didn't change anything
the only thing they changed was the
amount of time they're going to pay for
it
so if we're going to tell you we're
going to raise revenue and taxes and
make some changes we've got three major
changes in this bill back better that we
should all be
very careful what we do there's a major
change in our tax structure major change
there's a major change basic in the
social services that we
we provide
and there's a major change in our whole
approach to climate
and the energy sector that's major
we get any one of those wrong and we're
in trouble
is that
just to clarify and and i i want to get
into some of these topics more deeply
but just to clarify are you concerned
about the speed with which it's moving
but interested in those policies or are
you skeptical of the party's approach on
those policies well
you know
again there's there's those three areas
i've talked to you about i probably have
differences with most of my colleagues
respectfully and these are all very
intelligent good people that mean well
and they're representing their
constituents i'm representing my
constituents
and we ought to respect that you know we
don't have any errors for margins uh
right now but uh
i've just never seen a piece of
legislation that we're telling you that
we're going to spend
take 1.75 trillion and here's how we're
going to pay for it all paid for
well if we're going to pay for something
and we're going to pick child care we're
going to pick basically child tax
credits we're going to pick
the care at the end of life for home in
home care helping elderly if we're going
to pick all of these things we want to
do
but one goes for three years one goes
for one year and maybe one other one
might go for the full 10 years do they
not intend for those programs that last
a full 10 years
well if you
intend for that to happen what's the
real cost
because we're either going to debt
finance it if we're not going to pay for
it or come back and change the tax code
again to try to get the revenue
something's got to happen create
programs that people get to like and
you've got to refund them well sure
our republican friends basically they
use the obamacare or affordable care act
they use that as a whipping boy and beat
the living crap out of us in the 2010
election 2012 2014 and then in 2016 the
dog caught the truck the car
and they couldn't even get rid of it
when they had this they had the
presidency the house and the senate and
couldn't repel it
so i can tell you if we keep sending
checks it's going to be hard to stop the
checks
let me ask you about obamacare though
because part of the party's strategy was
to create it
keep it alive keep it going it was
controversial when it created the
democratic party took a
a whipping in 2010.
it's becoming 12 14 and 16. but it but
but but it has become more popular with
time yeah that's the strategy to an
extent isn't it so
even if it costs in the short term the
argument the argument that the advocates
of the programs would say is
take a little pain but over time it's
the right thing for the country and
people will like it it wasn't universal
care and we never intended for universal
care some do and some is trying to back
door universal care we wanted basically
a hybrid if you will can it fill the
gaps in small businesses in rural areas
where the economics aren't as
as as healthy in other areas and i think
that has stepped in and done that
and like i said
a pre-existing condition
that was the biggest factor the biggest
factor that kept the affordable care act
i won the 2018 election on one issue
pre-existing condition my opponent
wanted to get rid of and i says you go
tell my grandmother you go tell my aunt
and all them that you know you have high
blood pressure you had a heart problem
and this and that we can't insure you we
can't take care of you and just everyone
everyone has somebody in a family that
it would have affected and it was very
very very popular
they tried to do a hybrid of that and
could never come up with one they did
one my friends were doing one and and i
i get along you know extremely well with
all my republican all 50 of my
republican friends and they were telling
me they said joe we got we think we got
some here i said well tell me what it is
well we've got
we're going to take care of pre-existing
condition
only if you didn't have a pre-existing
condition
i said that'll sell well
that was so well
i want to ask you a little bit more
about climate and i'm not thinking
specifically in buildback better but
yeah i'm not thinking specifically
uh what may be in the bill but in a
general sense
i think you've generally said
the government doesn't need to pay for
what's already happening is that uh in
terms of the transition
there is a argument that your state
particularly though has been has lost a
lot of jobs in the climate transition
and stands to lose more
and that
there's investment to be made there's
opportunities to be made to employ
people to bring jobs if the government
can help
we are seeing plants come in north
carolina
georgia kentucky
is west virginia in on that kind of
action enough well we sure want you all
to come to west virginia we need you and
we'll give you good hard workers and
we'll do the tough jobs we'll do the
heavy lifting we always have the thing
about climate is this it's global
climate
it's not north american climate it's not
united states climate it's not west
virginia climate is global climate and
if you look at basically the reduction
transition they want to pay 150 billion
dollars to utility companies to start
reducing four percent a year okay and i
said okay you're going to pay us
something we're already doing they said
what do you mean i said well
and in the year 2000 52 percent of our
electricity you know energy came like
from our power plants was cold
coal-fired 52
we're down to 19 now
so we're moving in this the transition's
happening
not just for the rest of the world the
government should let it happen and stay
out of the way government government the
government can't do everything for us
you follow me because they'll screw up
an entire country if they do
what we can do is is this how do we
transition in a way that makes sense i
said you cannot eliminate your weight a
cleaner environment you can you can
innovate your way to a cleaner
environment you can't eliminate it and
here's the thing they said well if we do
it the rest of the world have fallen i
said really
in 2000 china had 1725 coal fire plants
they got 3 000 now they're building 400
more
we had 585 around 600 we got 504 we
reduced 33 percent they've increased
theirs
it's unbelievable what's going on around
the world india everywhere we're the
only nation that's decreased our fossil
and our fossil use but 40 percent of it
was replaced by natural gas now methane
and larger our large drilling companies
are doing a good job with methane we
have some of our smaller conventional
wells that we've got to fix but there
are some things we can do but i'll tell
you one thing if you don't pay attention
to reliability what mother nature did in
texas
and 200 people lost their lives in texas
this will be self-inflicted by 2030 if
we went down this plan so you're
skeptical of a government plan to
speed transition incentivize transition
incentivize plants
invest
you're skeptical of of government i'm
just saying marketing the market usually
has always picked the winners and losers
we have done a horrible job of picking
winners and losers we've been good at
aspirational desires and using your
money for that but not really picking
the winners and losers so if you're
going to say that take evs
electric cars are wonderful except we
don't have any basis of building it and
relying on it i said i'm old enough to
remember waiting in line in 70s
nope basically shut the oil off and i'd
look and see my license plate if i could
buy gas that day it affected our lives
it really did changed everything and we
saw
runaway inflation everything going on
i said you're going to be putting our
evr our transportation fleet in the
hands of foreign supply chains
that's what you're doing so at least i
was able to separate out of the by uh
bipartisan infrastructure bill
to where we go down a hydrogen path too
we can make all the hydrogen we want we
should not put all of our eggs in one
basket if we do i think we'll be
sorry for that you mentioned inflation a
couple times
um that's real well what's the effect on
your people in your state right now well
you know people talked about
in west virginia they want to know what
happened to the west virginia democrat
our chain our state changed more than
they stayed in the nation quicker than
any state we were two-thirds majority of
all democrats now we're two-thirds
majority of all republicans how could it
change so quick and i said i don't know
you know when i was at the i was at the
kennedy awards
sunday
and it was the 50th anniversary and they
had a flashback of john kennedy and all
of us were old enough i was a young
child i was 13 years old and i remember
him giving a speech and watching
television and i never forget that that
you know ask not what your country can
do for you ask what you can do for your
country and i still think in rural
america and i know in west virginia we
still feel that way we have to
contribute and participate
something's being lost here and my
washington democrats don't seem to get
it so i do want to get into that but on
inflation specifically just to ask
are it's heard people are feeling it
they're blaming washington
washington
who would you blame your citizens yeah
for the for the spending bills
essentially that's yeah
is jerome powell the right guy to fix it
well i don't know you know on that and i
had a conversation with him i have more
of a comfort level with him now and i
did but i still have some unanswered
questions i'm concerned about i thought
he was too
uh
he wasn't hawkish enough as far as on
on controlling basically women we were
able to stave off
a
uh health crisis and a financial crisis
and he started buying 120 billion
dollars a month in april i understand
quantitative easing buying our bonds and
buying our our debt
never stopped
never took the foot off the pedal we're
still buying it and they said oh now
we're gonna so i've been raising a lot
of cane about that now they're going to
come back and say we're going to reduce
at 15 15 billion a month okay you're
clear up until next year they're sending
more hawker signals than that they might
start raising they're saying because
we're pushing the living daylights i
said listen come on you're going to have
to get hawkish if you can don't let this
run away inflation kill us because we've
seen that happen before you're more
comfortable with them than you were
meaning
meaning i want to have another
conversation
okay so you're not there yet you're not
you're not buying it and you're talking
about west virginians i would say this
about inflation how hard the sitting is
we tr our our average worker drives 50
miles a day for a job
so we have one of the largest transits
in the country 25 one way 25 home with
that and food and now with utilities
going to be spiking utility prices this
is real this is hurting people so
they're saying well how come these bills
aren't more popular it's going to help
your state
well
they're just seeing what's really
affecting him now you've been trying to
help him we've spent 5.4
trillion dollars out the door we have
another 1.2 with the bipartisan
infrastructure bill we've done so many
good things in the last 10 months and no
one's taking a breath you know to have a
little breathing room and i said
5.4 i couldn't get my head around 5.4 so
i said give me something to compare it
to world war ii
we saved the world the united states of
america saved the world world war ii and
then you had the marshall plan we built
europe today's dollars is 4.7 trillion
4.7 trillion today's dollars so compare
what we've got for what we've done with
the debt before the deficit much higher
now
i want to ask you about one other policy
that i do want to talk a little bit of
politics but
you've been against the president's uh
osha vaccine mandate for private
business hold on we'll get that
corrected chuck schumer well chuck
schumer went at that bill today a little
bit i think um we've got this new and
contagious variant and your state i
think has had a low vaccination rate so
what
you don't favor the ocean mandate right
but what should government or i
basically am 1 percent in favor of the
federal government having a mandate that
anyone working for a federal government
paycheck anyone in the military should
have it because basically we're working
for your tax dollars and my tax dollars
for the services that you depend on what
about private businesses private
businesses know and i'll tell you the
reason why if there's a hundred
employees or more that's all it affects
they've done something right i don't
think they're gonna give up their market
shares or subject their employees
and lose their customers base
because of not making good decisions and
i don't think the government has to make
every decision for the private sector
you know you've been doing quite well
without is there a better approach than
a mandate that the government i've
always said incentivize don't penalize
if there's different programs that we're
letting you borrow into or things you
know you're accessing
then we'll incentivize
and then they can make a decision is
this worth it to us to get involved in
this program or not
but i wouldn't penalize i i just won't
do it i got to ask you i i i'm
i do want to talk politics but just
because you know chuck schumer blasts
the bill today i think we all know it's
pretty hard to go
very many days without some even
somebody these days in your party
blasting you or people you know
criticizing you
you may you
you may be the key vote you probably are
the key vote on this democratic bill
whether it gets through or not
um two questions about that one
does it bother you to be kicked around
like that or how do you deal with it
here's the thing matt i've told people
if you look at my record and my my
involvement in public service i've never
changed
i i have never changed i am the same
person i says
i'm i'm
fiscally
responsible and socially compassionate
and i think there's probably 60 70 80
percent of americans look but hasn't
your party changed i mean there's
there's a lot of voices in your party
the progressive changes
yeah i'm not a washington democrat
and i'm i'm i guess i'm a rural democrat
or an old west virginia democrat or you
know i still believe in and my
republicans are not my enemies they're
my friends we just have different
opinions
i don't approach anything like well
they're wrong and i'm right i need the
input of everybody and when we don't
have bipartisan buy-in usually you don't
get anything that lasts it won't last
they'll change it as soon as they get in
power then this makes sense so are you
waiting for just for the world to come
back your way or would you ever leave
the party or be an independent because
you do
you are caught between the two there's
no doubt about it i'm caught between the
two but the bottom line is you have to
be caucusing somewhere you follow me and
and uh if if they would ask me to leave
i i
i would just have to say i guess uh
we'll have to abide by your wishes i
don't know i don't think that'll happen
i don't tend to leave
but i intend to be honest you feel more
a democrat than a republican still it's
just hard you know the hard thing is is
that
you know i watch my grandparents i watch
my parents i think i've always said this
we're all a product of our environment a
lot of us are who we are because of how
we're raised where we're raising who
raised us and i saw the compassion i
just i just saw the good and the
compassion that they had for people
wanting to help people all the time
now i don't relate that the dumb
republicans don't because i have a lot
of good republican friends that feel the
same as i do
that middle has gotten so small there's
not many of us left here
i don't
but why is that though i mean you know
why aren't there 10 joe manchins and
kirsten cinemas in the senate instead of
two
why are i mean really both parties more
on the fringes that way because i think
you're partly saying you feel
you're more where a lot of americans are
than
the extremes in either party but i feel
comfortable i feel comfortable why is it
advised so much about the two of you why
aren't there more like the two of you
yeah i've never had to be able i never
had to think oh did i say something
different last year or the year before
i've been pretty much right where i am
now so anything i've told my colleagues
i said if you guys are upset just go out
and elect more liberals i'm not liberal
i don't know what to tell you
i love you all i'm just not i don't try
to change bernie
bernie is true to himself i respect and
appreciate that why they want to change
me he's actually he's actually a model
of sticking to your guns and letting the
tides of history come around bernie and
i can show you how to anchor both ends
so are the democrats headed for a
shellacking next year well i would say
that the the the warning uh the warning
lights are up they should be concerned
why why i just don't i don't know if
we're i mean there's so much good you
know i brought something and here's what
people i'm going to give this to you so
you can use it okay but it tells you let
me tell you if you all know the
deposition no i'm kidding
900 we did remember in december when was
deadlocked for five months couldn't make
a deal it wasn't the leadership that did
the democratic public it was five ds and
five hours we got together so we got to
do something so we come up with a 908
bill remember that got that one done got
us through and then we had the
bipartisan energy act which you haven't
heard much about
first time in 12 years we ever did an
energy act
for the bipartisan me and lisa murkowski
then we did
the hate crimes bill passed 94 to one
haven't heard much about that everyone
thought that was going to be a big
political fight we did the emergency
supplemental emergency supplementals
which could have been really politicized
we did that with unanimous consent we
did on top of that june uh
juneteenth national holiday that could
have been politicized
stand unanimous consent republican so we
did all these things so this is so
you're so you're saying but you all have
to get along because the party hasn't
told them what they're doing yeah
and we're doing it in a bipartisan way
you think the party's not telling its
story well but it's a good story to tell
both parties should be telling this
story democrats and republicans says we
can work together don't throw the baby
out with the bath water don't get rid of
the
the the the bipartisan spirit that we
have there the spirit of the senate and
i think from the founding fathers can
you imagine when when washington or
jefferson had to go and said we're going
to have a bicameral body and we have a
people's house over here which is the
house representatives and we're going to
have a senate and he had to go and tell
big bad new york and had to tell
virginia
that guess what
rhode island and delaware is going to
have exactly the same representation
you're going to have you'll both have
two
now you think they weren't thinking
about the minorities participation in
this process of ours well but senator
but senator you're you are a democrat so
your party takes a shellac you're saying
i'm gonna sound like one no no i'm
saying i'm saying your party let's say
your party takes a shellacking next year
senator mcconnell last night seemed i
think reasonably confident that it was
shaping up to be a republican year
democrats are back in the minority isn't
that worse for your position to get
things done that you want to get done
and and what would you what do you tell
your fellow democrats about where where
you think they've gone wrong
well we should be taking advantage of
the opportunity to work with our
with our colleagues
as we have done in that you i'm going to
give that for you take that with you no
but but but but i'm just saying but
there's not but realistically there's
not much reward for people politicians
in either party not today these days
to be seen to be working across my
republican colleagues i've told them i
said guys i don't know how did you you
were with me on january the 6th
that was not a visit to the capitol by
those people okay they came after us
and now to not even acknowledge it
and now not to acknowledge you've got 40
million people that don't acknowledge
that joe biden was the duly elected
president we had 40 million people on
the other side when donald trump
if we can't basically
if we can't basically have a transfer
how do we solve that i mean you're going
to have to stand tall before don't be
afraid of getting getting defeated
this is not the best job i've ever had
i swear to you
and
and i don't know i said the consolation
is send me home
i am not going to sell my soul
for this
well we're just about a time although we
can go on for a while if you don't mind
i want to ask you
quickly but i i think it's an issue you
feel strongly about i know you're very
concerned about opioids
your state's been hit hard we've had two
presidents in a row
who've talked forcefully and i think
sincerely
about the opioid challenge but a few
weeks ago as we saw drug overdose deaths
at a 12-month high across a hundred 000
how do we address this problem well
you know
when this started way back when all of
us thought it was a choice
then we found out it was an illness
like mental illness like any other type
of addiction it's an illness and you
have to treat it with treatment centers
we don't have enough treatment centers
you know
we and you support government funding
for treatment centers
let me tell you what i did support what
i the bill that i have and you might not
have heard of it and maybe you don't
agree with me
i thought that basically the way this
product come onto the market should
never come onto the market the way it
did
misleading the pit public thinking
that's going to be a wonderful
piece of uh pain relief that's not going
to be addicted
and here we go down that path and you
couldn't return you know the fifth well
the fifth element of wellness was pain
for them from the military that's where
this really as i'm told really got its
roots and started and it
came out and my brother's a doctor i
said hey john
how much uh how much training have you
had on dispensing
he says oh about two weeks out of eight
years 18 years of education
so they rely on whoever comes in and
tells them what to do and the scenario
i've said okay we got a problem now i
need a cure
so i have what a bill called uh the uh
lifeboat and lifeboat is this if you're
gonna produce this product these opiate
products
then you're gonna pay one penny per
milligram for treatment centers and
treatment centers only
we need treatment centers all over this
country gonna cure this problem and that
one penny is two billion dollars a year
that tells you the enormity of the
problem we have part of the problem
right now is illegal opiates though
right i mean i know when i go to my drug
store i assume for you
opiates are much harder to get they're
locked up i went to the hospital this
year i couldn't get demerol we've done
everything we can but we are being
flooded with fentanyl dangerous fentanyl
other drugs
are we doing it well to come across the
border and we got to have border control
we've got to have border security and i
don't care what democratic republican
how they might believe and it should not
be politicized but you've got to have
border security people need to come to
this country the right way we don't have
it no we don't we had a 2013 bill
bipartisan bill that was worked on it's
a great piece of legislation and it
basically gave people a pathway to
citizenship
and we have people that came here as you
know and
they were babies that were brought here
they should have a pathway if you go in
the military you go look in the military
who's serving right now i was up to the
to the uh
to the missile sites up in alaska
all puerto rican national guard
so i'm just saying everybody's
contributing
did we have security do you think under
president trump we had border security
do you think what he did he was moving
in that way but it wasn't a
compassionate way there's a you got to
have that compassion with the sternness
that we're going to do this okay and
have a pathway for it and basically you
can't entice people by giving them
benefit packages
that that's hard to explain to the
american public we're giving benefits to
people who haven't been haven't come
through the proper way
also we have to be compassionate the
people that are here that contributed
society should be made part of this
society and i can tell you right now the
lack of workforce we have we need a good
solid immigration policy it allows
people to come for the right reason
not come through the wrong way for the
wrong reason and that takes security
very last thing and i will over i'll let
you go but
president biden will he run again in
2024 and should he run again
well the people would decide that and
him and his wife jill will decide that i
think joe biden is the right person the
right place the right time for us right
now we just have to come together and i
have said this when donald trump was
president i did everything i could to
work with him i think all of us as
americans owe it to the president we
want your prayer you want all of us as a
good american wants your present to
succeed if they do well we all do well
but you have to be honest speaking you
know and you have to be able to speak to
power truth to power and tell them and
sometimes it's hard when you're sitting
in a white in the white house and you're
set in the oval office and just you and
the president are there and
they said i really need you on this and
says oh here we go
well we can only be a tough one we can
we can only imagine the conversations oh
we've had some good we have you know
each other well and i've had great ones
with senator with the president trump
yeah i've enjoyed you know what is the
next time you expect to be in the oval
office having the president to have that
conversation with you would you say
christmas eve
yeah we'll see
i've been all over so
the main thing is i
all of us this is a wonderful country we
have and the opportunities and all of us
all of us have that opportunity to
experience this american dream we want
it for everybody but we've got to work
together we're turning our country apart
because of politics
politics has become a blood sport you
know and i never
when john kennedy was running in 1960 i
was 12 years old 13 just going 13. and i
see my mother i mean we're catholic
family so i saw my parents and
everybody's all excited and and i'm
thinking i've never seen him excited
about politics before why are they so
excited so
this is he's a catholic running he's
young about the same age as they were
and i'm thinking oh boy this is good
okay that's who i'm for so we're
standing there watching them had to be
one with walter cronkite one night matt
and he says it's been said that if john
f kennedy becomes president the pope
will run the country and i look at my
mom i said boy mom they don't know the
catholics we do
so religion you know
religion used to be the thing that kind
of kept us
at the table kitchen table not talking
about because people would get upset
can't talk about politics anymore it's
awful politics you bring you together
fix the problem
and if you're not willing to do that you
want to throw the filibuster out and
just throw caution to the wind
then we'll not have the
i think we won't all have the prestige
we have we'll not be a superpower if we
lose that i really believe that because
then
we won't be consistent enough to where
people can say okay america's dependable
they might you know like winston
churchill says uh don't worry about the
americans don't worry about the
americans but doing trying to get us in
world war ii yeah they'll always do the
right thing when they've tried
everything else
okay
senator williams don't worry we're going
to do everything we'll try everything
maybe first but we'll do the right thing
we have to leave it there we'll all be
watching i expect we'll all be reading
your name a lot in the coming weeks and
we'll i wish that would not be the case
but you're probably right yeah okay
thanks
you